I want to pull up this story we got this
from The Wall Street Journal Israeli air
strike uh uh hits jabalia refugee camp
and forces extend their Advance into
Gaza Strip we have live updates
apartment buildings were flattened in
the strikes Egypt said it would defend
its its territory but take in wounded
Palestinians so I think we have a a clip
from C that I'll play for you well I
don't know if basically this is from
Ahmad uh Eline he says Wolf Blitzer you
knew that there were innocent civilians
in the refugee camp right IDF
spokesperson says this is a tragedy of
War let me just play the clip because I
don't want anything being taken out of
context for you guys so we'll just uh
we'll play this clip for you now but
even if that Hamas Commander was there
amidst all those Palestinian refugees
who are in that in that jabala refugee
camp Israel still went ahead and Dropped
a Bomb there attempting to kill killed
this Hamas uh this Kamas Hamas Commander
knowing that a lot of innocent civilians
men women and children presumably would
be killed is that what I'm
hearing that's not what you're hearing
wolf we again were focused on this
Commander again who you'll get more data
who this man was killed many many
Israelis uh we're doing everything we
can these are it's a very complicated
battle space there could be
infrastructure there there could be
tunnels there we're still looking into
it and we'll give you more data as the
hour moves
ahead I mean you know that there are a
lot of refugees a lot of innocent
civilians men women and children in that
refugee camp as well
right this is the tragedy of War wolf I
mean we wow as you know we've been
seeing for days move South civilians are
not involved with Hamas please move
South I'm just trying to get a little
bit more information you knew there were
civilians there you knew there were
refugees all sort of refugees but you
decided to still drop a bomb on that
refugee camp attempting to kill the
samas commander by the way was he
killed I can't confirm yet I mean wolf
should have just let him answer the
question then he just jumped to another
one we get the point Israel says They
Carried an air strike that Hamas Clan
killed him more than 50 people in gaza's
jabali refugee camp dozens of bodies
here here's here's my issue with this uh
that that CNN interview yeah damning but
they but Hamas lied about that about the
hospital and many on the left prop
Palestinian groups and left lied about
the hospital so when stories like this
come out what am I supposed to do I
don't know about the hospital frankly
I'm not sure that the story has really
been disb debunked that well it has they
claimed the they claimed the hospital
was leveled and 500 well the hospital
wasn't leveled they hit the parking lot
yep and it may have been a couple dozen
injured with with a certain certain
number of deaths we don't know but
there's been other hospitals hit and
they've told them to get out out of the
other hospitals they've said evacuate
these hospitals then they tell them
they're going to bomb the north so move
South while they're bombing the South um
this is unbelievable so there's nowhere
for these people to go they're shooting
fish in a barrel and they've got them
trapped there in a in a a virtual
concentration camp I'm sorry if that
sounds like leftist rhetoric but these
people are in a walled area No E no exit
no exit what do we do nothing should the
US just back away we should not have
first of all the UN had a a movement to
have a a ceasefire and we were one of
like seven countries that refused to go
along with it Hillary Clint Hillary
Clinton is very anti-fire there was a
ceasefire when Hamas made initiated the
the terrorist attack like three weeks
ago there was a ceasefire between Gaza
and Israel then Hamas broke the
ceasefire that's what started this whole
shindig that's going on now it's it's
very T you know listen I'm not going to
adjudicate the whole history of the
region but there's no way October 7th is
the beginning of this yeah that's why
that's why I'm kind of like I got I got
I got a really good idea you guys we
should not be involved exactly it's like
you're there's a very serious fight
happening between two of your neighbors
and people keep asking you whose side
you're on I'm like bro I don't live
there I don't know what's going on
they're like yeah well like you know
your kids like you're your your your dad
is giving weapons to one of your
neighbors and you're like maybe we
shouldn't be doing that I don't think
that there's actually any good answer
for the United States at all because I
don't think that we should give any
money I don't think we should be funding
I don't think we should have we should
in any be involved in it but I also
don't think that if we do what is the
right thing for the United States which
is not fund it not give any money not
support we're still going to be
implicated and we're still going to be
attacked even if we're not dealing with
actual Terror attacks we're still going
to be considered the evil Satan that
supports Israel and whatever just
because of our history yeah I mean it
doesn't help that we bombed Iraq for no
you know for complet under a completely
false pretext killed hundreds of
thousands of people and created millions
of ref
any amount of like backpedaling now
where we if we were to just suddenly
start backing away from any funding of
War would make us look like the ultimate
Hypocrites in the I think so look Trump
trump gets elected to the to them to to
the people on the other side of the
other ones that are if you're talking
about the people in Gaza or Hamas
they're going to look at I mean they're
going to look at as Hypocrites anyways
see I just strongly feel this is an
anti-western movement the reason so the
Palestinians that are on the ground in
you know in Israel or in Gaza or
whatever they hate the Israelis because
they have that direct actual situation
they're they're fighting them they're
being oppressed by the the Israelis and
and that's the situation for them the
out the the broader context where you're
talking about the region and other
countries sometimes Western countries
the people that are pro Palestine and
against the Israelis they're more about
being against the West more broadly
they're against Western Society they
don't they tend to not be uh they not
they tend to not be supportive of
democracies they want more authoritarian
types governments so it's not and I'm
not saying that I have an answer I'm
just I'm this is just west lived up to
its proclaimed values perhaps they
wouldn't feel that way I mean the West
has colleges have kind of implicated
that to them and I mean go further down
to Tik Tok and all these other ways in
which kids get this messaging now like I
don't know how much of that would even
matter now I do agree like I don't think
we should be funding any side of it but
I think that what it's created for me is
what I call I'm inan a like it's post
it's like a post concern attitude where
it's like there's so much information
there's so much propaganda there's so
much coming out from every side in a
part of the world that I inherently have
nothing to do with other than my
government's continued intrusion in
other people's business what am I what
am I as an American citizen whose taxes
are going to fund all this what am I
actually supposed to do in this
situation you're telling me I have to
care about this side they're telling me
I have to care about this side I'm not
allowed to care about the people here
apparently that's the only people you're
not allowed to care about hold on which
people the Americans people actually
living Americans though like okay how
about the people I mentioned last how
about the people in Hawaii how about the
people in any of the things that have
gone on here in the last several years
help helping trim down the debt in this
country all of the things that we have
to worry about State Side before we go
and start getting back reinol in other
countries we might we might revolt
against the fact that they're robbing us
to do this I mean they're robbing the
American public the American taxpayer to
to fund these wars I think Trump was one
of the first attempts of people saying
we will rationally decide this man will
enact many of these things and uh now
things are getting pretty tense with the
machine's desperate attempts to keep
Trump out of office yeah I mean it's
it's crazy when we have uh Scott Horton
of all people being like Trump tried
getting our troops out and they lied to
us he tells he tells the truth about
these matters and but Trump wasn't some
you know say I mean he he killed
solomani for for uh you know and could
have that could have instigated some
conflict with Iran imagine if if Iran
had killed one of our major generals I
mean this would have drawn us into war
the only reason they didn't get drawn
into war is because we have a greater
force but that's not the way the United
States should be uh acting ac across the
planet we ought to be the beacon on the
hill in the sense that we are free
people that people admire that trades
with other countries is cooperative and
peaceful this would actually promote
peace worldwide it is true Phil that
what you said about it being an
anti-American movement did you see the
the infographic meme the other day it
says free Palestine is a queer movement
free Palestine is uh okay that's at the
heart of it it's an anti-western
anti-democracy movement more than
anything else it's not that they support
or love Palestine or Gaza it's that they
love the fact that it puts the West
between a rock and a hard place in
dealing with the conf because there and
you're right because there is no good
policy that's going to to make the
United States look good I personally
like I've said over and over we
shouldn't be involved we shouldn't have
troops over there we shouldn't be
spending money on it we shouldn't be
funding it Israel can fight its own War
I like I 100% believe that but that
doesn't mean that if that were the
course of action that the United States
took that the rest of the world would be
like oh cool the United States is doing
the right thing or the good thing there
are still going to be people that are
going to say oh the West is bad America
is bad democracy bad liberalism bad yeah
I mean when you when you try to export
democracy uh with bombs like we did in
Iraq of course people are going to be
skeptical about what is this democracy
you're talking about yeah I I agree and
I just don't think that I don't think
that it that it's I don't think that
it's limited to the Middle East I I
think that that there is an anti-western
anti- liberal movement that is pretty
Global it's I think there's an
anti-liberal movement in the United
States I don't think I don't think there
are any liberals left we're looking at
an illiberal left effectively but you
know there's there's no liberalism here
there are it's just they're the post-
Liberals they're the the disaffected
Liberals the the funny part is is like
in what I do like talking about movies
celebrities Hollywood and pop culture
you see this right now because a bunch
of celebrities try to make a post that
makes everybody happy and they can't
make anyone happy and this is the first
time they haven't been given a clear
marching order about who the good guys
and who the bad guys are when they write
their virtue signaling letters uh
everyone gets mad at them from every
side and I think that the people that
are inherently anti-American and
anti-western love that about this yeah
you see I think you see the the the
people that
are only ter that only understand the
wave Toops of the movement the one are
those those are the people that are
shocked when they are kind of learning
what decolonization means and that it's
a violent revolution that's being
endorsed and and they're shocked they're
like wait a minute I didn't I don't want
to see people getting their heads cut
off I don't want to see you know
people's businesses and lives being
destroyed well that's what
decolonization is we could jump back to
the China thing okay what are we what
are we doing with reference to China
That's weakening us well we're we're
doing all kinds of things we're
instituting a de de-industrialization
campaign in the west uh with the ESG and
the stakeholder capitalism which is
about eroding our industrial base uh
supposedly to uh mitigate so-called
climate change and G uh greenhouse gas
emissions and this is you know this is
favoring China that's something that
we're doing to ourselves it's a
self-inflicted wound it's a you know
suicidal in effect we're taking our
Industries and we're saying you can't
burn fossil fuels and we must use this
ESG to force all these companies into
these uh into this regime while China
then gains all this power and and wealth
on the on the back end because they're
not doing it thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net